-Donald Trump has endorsed
one of the most pro-MAGA
members of the Republican Party,
Ohio congressman Jim Jordan,
to be the next
Speaker of the House,
which could put one of
the most prominent supporters
of the coup attempt on January
6th in charge of the chamber.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
When last we left
the House Republican caucus,
several of them
were organizing an effort
to draft Donald Trump himself
to be the next speaker,
which is possible since
technically the speaker
does not have to be
a member of Congress.
Apparently, it doesn't even need
to be a sentient human being.
It could be one of those air
dancers outside car dealerships.
Republicans would probably
love that
because it has the same
hand movements as Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
And apparently Trump was serious
about at least considering
a bid to become speaker.
Politico reported
last week that...
Should he even be allowed
back in the Capitol,
based on what happened
last time he was there?
I mean, I'm on a year ban
from Vrbo
because some guy said
I rented his place,
after I rented his place,
the Q went missing
from the Scrabble game.
But Trump,
Trump foments an insurrection
and is allowed to come
and go as he pleases.
Also, the Q
was already missing, dude.
[ Laughter ]
But I guess Trump
is allowed back.
In fact, his best bud
Sean Hannity
claimed on air last week
that sources were telling him
Trump was open to the idea
of becoming speaker.
Now, again, keep in mind
as you watch this clip,
Hannity isn't just a pundit
who interviews Trump.
He's appeared onstage with Trump
at rallies,
and during Trump's presidency,
the two reportedly talked
on a near nightly basis
before bedtime.
According to
"New York Magazine,"
on the phone, Hannity and Trump
alternate between the witch hunt
and gabbing like old girlfriends
about media and gossip
and whose show sucks and who's
getting killed in the ratings
and who's winning and sports
and Kanye West,
all of it sprinkled
with a staccato [bleep]
[bleep] [bleep] [bleep]
So Trump and Hannity
aren't just media allies,
they're best buds,
which is context for this clip
in which Hannity claims
sources were telling him
Trump was open
to becoming speaker.
-Sources telling me at this hour
some House Republicans
have been in contact with
and have started an effort
to draft former president
Donald Trump
to be the next speaker.
And I have been told
that President Trump
might be open to helping
the Republican Party,
at least in the short term,
if necessary.
-So the source was Trump.
Whenever you hear
Sean Hannity float something
like that on television,
it's because it's something
Donald Trump told him to say
or, at the very least, it's
something Trump wants to hear.
At this point,
I wouldn't be surprised
if Trump was writing
the Fox News chyrons
live in real time
via voice to text.
And Trump himself
essentially confirmed
the veracity of this report
when he was asked
about the possibility
of becoming speaker last week
at his fraud trial
in a Manhattan court.
-Would you take the job?
Would you take the job?
-Trump will always say
he's considering something
when you first ask him about it.
The reporter could stand up
at a press conference
and say, "Mr. President,
sources are telling us
you're considering jumping
into the gorilla enclosure
at the Bronx Zoo
and challenging the largest ape
to a wrestling match
in order to subdue him,
claim his territory, and become
king of the primates."
And Trump would say, "We're
looking very strongly at it.
I'm certainly -- I'm certainly
getting a lot of calls
saying, 'You're the only one
who can defeat Mongo.'"
But as random and insane
as this idea sounds,
it apparently did not
come out of nowhere.
Over the weekend,
ABC News reported
that Trump actually maneuvered
behind the scenes
to become Speaker of the House
back in January.
And apparently the reason
he did that
was because he was angry
he wasn't getting more votes
during the initial
rounds of voting.
-Sources tell ABC News
former president Trump
secretly plotted to be elected
Speaker of the House in January
while he was publicly supporting
now-former speaker
Kevin McCarthy's bid.
-Publicly, Donald Trump
had endorsed Kevin McCarthy
for speaker.
But what I've learned is that
when Trump saw Matt Gaetz
step up on the seventh ballot
back in January
and vote for Donald Trump
for speaker
and then he saw
all the cable networks,
you know, relay the vote count
and it was only
a single vote for Trump --
you know, 212 votes
for Hakeem Jeffries,
200 for Kevin McCarthy,
some others had
a handful of votes,
and then only one
for Donald Trump --
Trump became angry
and he actually reached out,
contacted Gaetz,
made his views known
within a small circle
of Republicans
that the only reason
he only got one vote
is that nobody bothered
to nominate him,
and so people didn't know
they could vote for him.
And at that point,
he made it clear
that he wanted Matt Gaetz
to nominate him
for Speaker of the House.
-Okay, so just to recap, Trump,
who was publicly supporting
now-former speaker
Kevin McCarthy,
but he was also mad
in the seventh round of voting
he only got one vote
for speaker.
I'm sure when he saw this,
his text to Hannity
looked like this.
[ Laughter ]
So Trump then asked
Congressman Matt Gaetz
to officially
nominate him for speaker,
assuming this meant the votes
would start pouring in for him.
And Gaetz did that.
He stood up, made a big speech,
and nominated Donald Trump
to be Speaker of the House.
So what happened
after Gaetz nominated him?
Did Trump get 100 votes
for speaker, 200 votes?
How close did he come?
-When that speech was over,
they called for the roll,
and they once again
did another round of voting.
And once again, Donald Trump
got a single vote
for Speaker of the House.
-Did he call Gaetz again?
[ As Trump ] I think this time
when you nominate me,
say, "I'm being serious,
you guys.
This isn't some dumb joke."
[ Normal voice ] It was so bad,
that night on "Hannity,"
the chyron said...
So Trump's last attempt to get
votes for speaker went badly,
which must be why
he's now abandoned
this latest bid for the job.
Instead, he endorsed
far-right extremist Jim Jordan,
perhaps the most pro-MAGA member
of the House GOP caucus
and one of the key players
in the attempt to overturn
the election on January 6th.
You might remember
Jordan as the guy
who would routinely show up
to hearings in the House
that were supposed
to be investigating
the Trump administration,
but instead talk really fast
and say totally incoherent
bull[bleep] like this.
-James Comey, director, fired.
Andy McCabe,
deputy director, fired,
lied three times under oath,
under investigation as we speak.
Jim Baker, FBI counsel, demoted,
then left, currently
under investigation
by the U.S. Attorney's Office
in Connecticut.
Lisa Page demoted, then left.
Ambassador Taylor recalls
that Mr. Morrison
told Ambassador Taylor
that I told Mr. Morrison
that I conveyed this message
to Mr. Yermak
on September 1, 2019,
in connection with
Vice President Pence's
visit to Warsaw.
-He sounds like an auctioneer
with a head injury,
just repeating
all the unhinged buzzwords
you hear on Fox News
without any of the content.
It's like
if Thanksgiving dinner,
everyone in your family
had a time limit to speak.
"Uncle Jerry,
what are you thankful for?"
"Well, I guess I'm thankful
for my health
and continued efforts
to stop trans, woke, Benghazi,
Whitewater, China, laptop,
Hunter e-mails, tan suit."
And it makes sense
that Jordan would spew
random Fox News talking points,
because he is far and away
the most popular Republican
congressman on Fox News.
Since August 2017...
565 times.
I don't even think
I've appeared on this show
565 times since 2017.
In fairness,
we did have that stretch
where I was replaced
by a guest host.
Who was that again?
Oh, damn it!
He's everywhere.
On the bright side,
it only took him
about 90 seconds to get
through "A Closer Look."
And when he does go on Fox News,
it won't surprise you to learn
he doesn't make
all that much sense,
like when he said this
over the weekend
about his bid to become speaker.
-The American people
right now, Maria,
I think are -- they are
so thirsty for leadership.
And I don't think they're seeing
it from the White House.
I don't think they're
getting it from the Senate.
They are hungry for leadership.
-Oh, they're thirsty and hungry?
"Maria, the American people
are thirsty for leadership.
They're hungry for leadership.
And dare I say,
they're horny for leadership.
Don't take it from me.
Take it from the audience
at the "Beetlejuice" musical."
But by far, the most
dangerous thing about Jordan
is that he was arguably
the most prominent supporter
in Congress
of Donald Trump's attempt
to overturn the 2020 election.
He was intimately involved
in the planning
of Trump's coup attempt,
and has flat-out
refused requests
to provide more information
about his involvement.
-Jim Jordan scored former
president Trump's endorsement
early this morning, which
should come as no surprise.
Here is Jordan in
Harrisburg, Pennsylvania,
attending a Stop the Steal rally
two days after Election Day.
In the weeks and months
after that,
Jordan went on various
right-wing media outlets
where he attempted to sow
distrust in the 2020 election
and made baseless claims
of election fraud.
Jordan's name appears
throughout the bipartisan report
from the House Select Committee
investigating January 6th.
The report says
that Jordan attended
numerous post-election meetings
with senior White House
officials and Rudy Giuliani
discussing how to challenge
the election results.
-I don't know what's
more shocking --
that people still have meetings
with Rudy Giuliani
or that Rudy Giuliani
made it to the meeting.
When he was told
to meet with Jim Jordan,
Rudy probably thought
he was meeting
in a gymnasium
with Michael Jordan.
[ As Giuliani ] Hey, Mike,
you've always been
my favorite baseball player.
Go, White Sox.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
A lot of time was spent today
on, what would Rudy say
to Michael Jordan in a gym?
[ Laughter ]
Trump endorsing Jordan
is a perfect encapsulation
of where the GOP
is at right now.
A vote for Jordan to speaker
is essentially a vote for Trump
and his efforts
to overturn American democracy.
Even if Jim Jordan is nominally
in charge of the House,
he's just going to be
following Trump's orders.
Trump is still the leader
of the Republican Party,
and Jordan is fully
devoted to him.
So I guess you could say
Jordan's the one who's...
-Thirsty for leadership.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]